From a world-ending apocalypse to yet more
timeline jumps and shenanigans, the third
season of The Umbrella Academy ends on a huge
cliffhanger and a big reveal about Reginald
Hargreaves.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining everything you need
to know about the ending of Season 3, what
the deal was that Allison made, and why we're
likely getting doppelgangers in Season 4!
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
When the Umbrella Academy arrived back in
2019 to find themselves replaced by the Sparrows,
on the same day they arrived, a Kugelblitz,
a type of black hole, appeared in the basement
of the Sparrow Academy.
You see, when they travelled back to the 60s
they inadvertently transferred powers to a
young Harlan, who as he grew up found himself
connected to other powered people.
When his mother, Sissy, died on the 1st of
October 1989, it was the same day the Umbrella
Academy's mothers were due to give birth.
As the super-babies grew inside them, Harlan
sensed their pain and when this combined with
his grief over Sissy's death, he accidentally
killed them, preventing the Umbrella Academy
team from ever being born.
So, when the gang arrive in this new timeline,
they shouldn't actually exist, and this creates
a version of the grandfather paradox.
A paradox?
You mean one of those things that could destroy
the universe?
The threat the Kugelblitz poses to the entire
cosmos now explains just why the Commission
was so alarmed when they found out about Harlan's
powers in the second season.
I've never seen anything like this.
The anomaly is off the charts.
The Kugelblitz is unstoppable without going
back in time to prevent their mothers being
killed, which is impossible as the only two
available Commission briefcases are broken.
The only remedy lies in the Hotel Oblivion.
The Oblivion is located in an alternate dimension,
a nod to how the hotel in the comics it exists
in a pocket dimension and was used by Hargreaves
as a prison for villains.
And the numerous cockroaches that keep popping
up are a reference to how the critters were
served to the prisoners at the hotel in the
comics.
In the TV show, the Oblivion contains a machine
that can rebuild the universe should it ever
be destroyed.
The machine is activated by the seven bells,
which it turns out are seven of the surviving
team.
And when they stand on the stars on the floor
of the hotel's lobby, they create the sigil,
which unlocks the machine.
The Oblivion then reveals that it's basically
an illusion for a Matrix-like machine that
controls the reality of the world.
Another cool detail here is the hotel floor
tiling that creates an optical illusion, another
pointer to the Hotel Oblivion's perception
and reality-altering powers.
The machine then begins to pull sparks of
light out of the seven members of the team,
something that Allison protests as it appears
to be about to kill them.
The particles inside their bodies are the
only things that fuel the machine.
Now, these flecks of lights are the ones that
Hargreaves released a long time ago back on
his home world.
And the opening scene of Season 3 confirmed
that they are the thing that miraculously
impregnated numerous women around the world
who, on the same day, all gave birth to super-powered
children.
And they're also the same lights that transferred
to Harlan in Season 2 to give him his powers.
And this makes me think it was part of Hargreaves'
plan to use humans as vessels for transferring
the magical lights from his home world, eventually
all the way to the Hotel Oblivion, where he
could then extract them to power up the engine
that would recreate the cosmos.
With access to the machine, I think he then
programmed the rebirth of the universe in
a way that would prevent the apocalypse on
his home planet and the death of his wife.
After all, remember that he said:
I've seen worlds end in ways that would knock
your socks off.
But you never forget your first.
Your home.
Your original sin.
You never stop wondering,
"Did I do enough to save the people I loved?"
Did you?
No, but I was hoping you children could help
me out with that.
Season 3 also revealed that bringing his wife
back to life has been a huge driving force
for Hargreaves, when we discover that he was
keeping her body cryogenically frozen in a
container on the moon.
He even sent Luther there for four years on
an unexplained mission to keep her safe.
You wasted my life on the moon, and for what?
I left you to guard the most precious thing
in the universe.
I even suspect that Hargreaves himself may
have cycled through various loops in time
in order to figure out what combination of
events would eventually lead him to discover
the key to fixing the universe in his favour.
In Season 1's flashback to Hargreaves arrival
in America, we can see from the immigration
stamp that this was 1928.
But in Season 3, we discover Hargreaves was
already on Earth in 1918 looking for the portal
to the alternate dimension.
Even after uncovering the portal, his attempts
to get safe access inside were thwarted by
the Guardians protecting the other side,
and when he saw how a group of trained soldiers
were so easily defeated by the samurai warriors,
that might have led him to the idea that he
needed a group of extraordinary, super-powered
individuals for the task.
For that, he might have gone back again in
time to release the magical lights, and since
then he's gone through many cycles of different
super-babies and children until finding the
seven who would become the seven bells.
Another big clue to Hargreaves' secret time
travel shenanigans is the fact there's a Televator
sign hidden in the basement of the Sparrow
Academy.
In the comics, the Televator is a contraption
that can travel across space, time and dimensions,
and in the Season-2 60s timeline we saw that
Hargreaves had blueprints in his office for
building a Televator.
As he said to Five, he's witnessed numerous
apocalypses before, so perhaps that's how
he's escaped through time and space on several
occasions.
And if you like this theory or this video
so far, hit that like button, I really appreciate
it.
But what was the deal Allison made with Reginald
on the night of Luther and Sloane's wedding?
I think she offered to unite her side of the
family by reconciling with them the following
day then trying to convince them to join Hargreaves'
mission to the Oblivion.
Although that didn't exactly work, she had
tried, and so once on the other side, in return,
perhaps out of some slight empathy for her
given his mission was also to recover his
lost love, Hargreaves programmed the new universe
so that she could have the two cherished things
she'd lost in all the timeline changes:
her daughter Claire from 2019, and her husband
Ray from the 60s.
I'm almost done.
And when I am, you and I will get what we
came here for.
This new universe is Allison's idealised world
where her mistakes and problems from the previous
two seasons are now gone.
In Season 1, after Allison's husband Patrick
found her using her powers on their daughter,
he divorced her and took custody of Claire.
And in Season 2, she had to leave her husband
Ray, who she'd fallen in love with, so that
she could travel back to the future.
Now, in this new and improved timeline, Allison
has managed to get the two people she loves
from different times in one place.
Reginald too got what he was finally after
too and created a world where not only is
his wife Abigail still alive, but once more
he's a billionaire, with what looks like an
even bigger business empire this time.
As for Allison's siblings, they emerge in
the new world dramatically changed.
Luther has lost his simian body, Diego's fingers
that were sliced off by one of the Guardians
have returned and Five also has both his arms.
The wrinkle, however, is that they don't have
their powers any more:
I can't blink.
Now, it's possible that they lost their abilities
when the particles were extracted out of them
by the Oblivion's world-reset machine, which
would also mean that Allison would still have
her powers, but it doesn't totally explain
how Luther is 100% human again, or how Diego's
fingers and Five's arm have returned.
And thanks to this cryptic final scene where
we see Ben riding the subway to a stop in
the financial district of Seoul, Korea, I
think that in Season 4, we'll be seeing doppelgangers.
The clues are subtle but notice how this Ben
doesn't have a scar on his face implying that
it isn't Sparrow Ben, plus his hairstyle is
different.
The scene is also a call-back to the opening
scene of Season 3 where a young Korean girl
on the subway is impregnated by the magical
lights and gives birth immediately.
Whether Ben was born that way in this new
timeline, we don't yet know, and therefore
we can't be sure whether this Ben has any
powers.
After all, Hargreaves may well have decided
that he didn't need to release any magic lights
this time after the adjustments he'd made
to the timeline with the machine at the Oblivion.
I think this final scene is also pointing
to the idea that in Season 4, we'll be getting
doppelgangers for the other Umbrella Academy
members as well.
Remember how at the start of Season 3, there
was specific mention by Five of how they could
expect to meet a copy of themselves in the
new timeline.
Dad didn't adopt us as babies, but those babies
still existed here.
Odds are, we each have identical versions
of ourselves.
Our doppelgängers!
Doppels probably aren't even in the same time
zone as us.
That never happened in Season 3 because the
Umbrellas' mothers all died before they gave
birth, but I think the point of Five bringing
up the subject was to set up the idea for
Season 4.
In other words, it's basically Chekov's Doppelgangers.
If the Umbrella gang's powers do return and
the doppels also have powers, it could be
fun if they get into an argument or fight
with themselves, much like Five did in Season
2.
Another theory I have about how the team might
regain their powers is with the help of a
Televator.
As I mentioned earlier, this machine can not
only travel through time and space, but also
between dimensions, meaning they could try
and return to their old universe before it
was Kugelblitzed, get back their old powers
and then stop the apocalypse.
A hint at this idea might be the fact that
they came into this new universe via the door
of an elevator from the Hotel Oblivion.
So, could that elevator itself be a secret
Televator with a hidden activation switch?
Also to be revealed in Season 4 is why Sloane
is missing in the final scene, given she was
with the others at the moment Allison pressed
the button?
I don't think she's been written out of the
show, especially given that Luther has run
off looking for her, and I suspect the opening
scene of her reading a travel book with the
Leaning Tower of Pisa on the cover is a hint
that she's ended up somewhere else, perhaps
Italy.
And we know when Sloane was with Luther, she
talked about wanting to get away.
I know there are better places out there in
the world, and one day, I want to see them
all.
I'm also curious to see what happens with
Lila and Diego, especially as she's pregnant,
whether they'll end up having a super-baby?
Another question is how is Luther back at
all, given he'd died?
Did the ghostly spirit of him that Klaus conjured
up at the Oblivion mean he could be reborn
into the new world?
Klaus chases after Luther, so there's something
between the two of them that will be explained
in Season 4.
In fact, there were some neat clues very early
on that predicted how both Klaus and Luther
would end up together in the afterlife, something
I explain in my Season 3 easter eggs and things
you missed video, which I'll be uploading
next.
I'll add a link here and in the description
as soon as it's ready.
So, Movie Lovers, what do you think about
the third season of The Umbrella Academy?
And do you have any theories on what will
happen next?
Comment with your thought below.
Next, tap here to discover all the incredible
easter eggs and little details hidden in Season
3.
And if you liked this video, do leave a thumbs-up.
Thanks for enjoying The Umbrella Academy with
me and hope you have a marvellous movie-loving
week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!